second are we live it's not showing
up oh there it goes all right we're live
um
hi we got some stuff to do today back on
the normal schedule for the most
part uh I've got
about 3 hours right now for morning
session and we'll be back in the
afternoon let's fix a couple of these
people's things really quick
first so
close yeah that's not bad this
uh this is not bad
uh
what if you change the
name
um that's weird
which is just th calorie mug V1 with
um actually Blended
properly not
bad it's just mediocre hot
chocolate with 1,000 calories a bunch of
protein
right
yeah
so this evidently ran a whole bunch of
well you can see there's like
this this band of hyper
parameters that it seems to
like it's a pretty wide stable region
actually I like this
I'm trying to think how we want to do
this so we've got this relative
time so I think we're going to just
start
filtering okay so stuff the trains in a
minute half of
them then we do
score okay now we have 27 perfect so
here are all of our top
runs welcome
hi we're doing uh a little bit of
analysis on the sweep from last night at
the moment hopefully this gives us a
better Connect 4
have these are all the
graphs I mean these pretty much are all
nice and stable
right greater than seven I'm streaming
in 1080 I should
be uh does it only show 720 on Twitch
YouTube
same let me figure that out real quick
that's very
oh is this it right
here yeah it's set to 720 let me reboot
the stream so I can do this it's not
going to let me uh I'm going to reboot
this this and then I'll be back in like
2 seconds and the